[Music]
in team scheme news submitted by I love
dogs teams are now falling victim to a
new pyramid scheme
sweeping Instagram what's that for real
it's a pyramid scheme the same as a
Ponzi scheme
I'm very similar but not really what the
Ponzi scheme yeah so Ponzi I think is
more related to stocks and stuff we're
like you you get like I formed this fake
stock company and then you give me money
to invest in the stock and then Julia
gives me money to invest in the stock
and I use Julia's money to pay you and
you think that you're making positive
interest in that so I'm going like this
like this it's kind of similar to a
pyramid scheme but then in a pyramid
scheme it's like I'm selling you this
it's we're selling we're an ax company
and to be a part of this ax company you
give me 300 bucks and now you can sell
this ax and I give it to you you take
that and then you go to David and then
so David is now becoming an axe salesmen
and he gives you a little bit of money
for that and it comes back up to me so
you get to keep like maybe $20 and then
I'll keep like you know the rest so it
just goes up the line so it's kind of
it's very similar on the top of it oh
yeah
not the bottom shits yeah the people who
start them off or always yes they are
no I'm saying yes I agree I don't want
to be a part of it the only type of
pyramid scheme I want to be is the I on
the dollar bill Illuminati secret
society if Jay Z's in it I want to be in
it so I could be like yo let's go hang
out jay-z and Beyonce
I'll be hung fat yeah so apparently now
teens are involved in this pyramid
scheme and so they pretty much just
change exchange money through Ben mo or
PayPal and they're promoting in on their
Instagram and snapchat and it looks like
this so it's a literal pyramid Wow
yeah and it can't even deny it yeah so
what they what they're doing here is
they're saying that if you're the yellow
star everyone that's a white star has to
pay 150 dollars to the yellow star and
then everyone once the yellow star gets
paid off then every way low star gets
bumped off everyone these people split
and then they end up being yellow stars
and then they have to recruit white
stars to get their muscle it's a pyramid
scheme for dumbasses so literally that's
what it is they're not even trying to
cover it up yeah you're gonna be a white
star right and then you know God yeah so
then like here's another example of it
so yeah they're just promoting it saying
you're definitely a hood person because
profitability stands for a we all eat it
yeah we all eaten in here yep yeah and
here's like an explanation of what it is
and they're pretty much saying what I
already said like everyone just recruit
white stars and then they'll get bumped
up and they're saying that at the end of
it all you'll get $1,200 and that's it
and then like this person saying like I
already joined two pyramids or you've
been calling it pyramid oh my god how
much does it cost to get on 150 and you
get 1,200 at the end of it when you
collect once here's a gold star
total how many stars are there there are
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 15
but only the white stars pay their way
in it's Oh only the whites okay but to
fill up all the positions including
yourself so the cost the total pyramid
is 2250 and then you get how much paid
out twelve hundred
oh so a thousand fifty goes to whoever
created it Wow a thousand a thousand
fifty for each pyramid that completes so
every single person that gets bumped up
over who started this [ __ ] I don't know
whoever started that [ __ ] is the person
that I want to be no you are they
tracing it because you could go to jail
yeah they're an original yellow star
person yep you gotta follow the money
where is it going yeah I'm not sure
exactly where this started they're just
talking about the fact that this is
something that teens are buying in and I
don't know I personally felt like it was
important for us to talk about and warn
you guys out there cuz I'm pretty sure
there's viewers out there that are
getting involved in this and it's
gambling like straight-up gambling its
first example yeah you'll get use just
giving money here you go oh I think
that's all that's happening do you think
the kids are looking at it as the kids I
don't know as if like they're like oh
well it's kind of like I'm saving money
like I'm moving my money around so they
might even take it because they're so
young and kind of naive they're kind of
taking it as like an investment I feel
like if you get to the top you don't
care because you only paid 150 yeah get
to the top and then you you're 150 made
1200 how'd you
but don't you start at the bottom so you
pay you pay 150 and then the more people
that you recruit you moving bumps up for
you so you're not using your own money
exactly so then for them they see it as
like dope I just made money with my
money right so if you're so I'm a little
slow obviously so the white ones are 150
yes and then they go into the blue
section or no yeah so then once all the
white spots get filled in then this
splits into two now these two people get
done yeah and then these moving to
yellow and I think this is what happens
let's say you're Jonathan right you
recruit somebody or whatever you go up
to here and then they two people fill up
this fake yeah or the three people and
then you go here and then if when this
space is filled up you go here Wow and
then they have to recruit eight more
people so then they can get pushed up so
I think I would do it as a kid I'm done
yeah yeah cuz all you see is the 1200
and you go oh if I just I just gotta
bring more people in yeah and I'm like I
have those kind of friends yeah and if
everyone's doing everyone's like oh I'm
done you're doing all yeah we're all a
circle of friends and then I would be
dumb enough to be like not all eating
I'm not even if I'm wife's Thor and I'm
stuck there and I ran out of friends
yeah exactly that's the thing like
people don't realize like you have
friends just be giving your money and
not get anything back ever and it could
just be the money circulating - yeah the
same money like we started a different
star but you're pretty much giving away
a thousand fifty so if that was all your
friends right you pile up a total of two
hundred two thousand two hundred fifty
so basically you have this total and
then instead of splitting it amongst
yourselves and just using it someone's
coming over and taking half of that
that's basically what's happening why
don't you know how kids are very
illogical especially when they're in
like their teens what if your kids get
into this and then you break it down
right like you break down the math you
like dude idiot like you're losing money
stop it but they're so naive or they're
like God mom or dad like you'll never
let me do it you just don't get it yeah
what do you do then uh-huh go ahead
loser cuz it wasn't their money that's
cool I said well that's the money that
you earned they don't want to let you
give them allowance yeah but they still
earned it though cuz in my house you're
[ __ ] watching the [ __ ] windows
[ __ ]
even though we have somebody they
understand profit he's already punishing
I hope that all the lessons that I teach
of there's no like real shortcuts to
getting successful or like making fast
money if those don't prevent them and I
didn't do a good job of that then if
they have to be stupid and invest
something like this word there's no
intrinsic value then [ __ ] it everyone's
got to make their own mistakes I also
believe that people learn better by
making mistakes jump yeah and if you're
like always preventing and giving
guidance and mentors like all of a
sudden you die out of nowhere and her
lifelong love daddy was always the
source of answers pyramid schemes I
think for me like I got recruited to a
bunch of them and they're always easier
to sniff out
because any times well I think the
streets the street smarts helped out
because anytime you can realize that
being a part of the organization makes
more money than the actual products
you're selling that's when things seem
fishy so we're like one of the ones I
got recruited by if you sell these
telephone lines each one's 30 bucks
think about all these telephones I could
be selling that's your mom your aunt
your whatever you're ready got ten and
I'm like wait so if thirty bucks that's
ten that's only $300 you're telling me
to pay five hundred dollars just to be
part of the organization right now
ten people to still be in to still be
$200 down and then here's I know but
that $500 you're a business owner and so
I can see like the other people in the
group like oh yeah business owner number
I was doing the Madeline lion eyelashes
I'll run up you there when I was gonna
get recruited to a pyramid scheme
they're like this is what you got to do
you got to talk to five people five oh
just like how can I be a part of this
scam no thank you for inviting me well
cuz I got lucky because my friend's
brother told me everything like so he
didn't really say anything like oh this
is I'm trying to convince you or
anything he was just like no this is
what goes on and I'm like okay bring me
in damn she older sibling cuz like she
she got into a pyramid scheme and then a
friend I might try to recruit me under
there I was like record uh a little bit
yeah but me should learn from it but
then like later a friend of mine tried
to recruit me and there I was like no I
don't want to go and he was like just
please just go through orientation I
just need help I'm like fine I'll just
do it as a homie so I just went there
and then like everybody else is trying
to convince me I was like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
all right now y'all parents game anytime
if you want to make full-time income on
a part-time basis that's one of their
favorite lines be careful for that one
yeah well little did they know how
[ __ ] lazy I am [ __ ] is we don't
normally do this but you can actually
leave the meeting
I want to go now like I want to go to a
pyramid scam like meeting now and troll
the [ __ ] out of it how would you tell it
like I would act really interested and I
believe in everything oh my god what's
sad about this one though is that it's
not even covered up it's not like we're
covering it up with a product with
makeup or covering up with nutrition or
or telephone lines it's just straight up
hey you could pay the way to the top
star but there's yeah that's how I guess
it's like a video game I actually want
to join this pyramid scam fast mmm-hmm
and I'll just bring myself up to the
pyramid by like paying for myself going
up and I cheat myself
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]